las intervenciones virtuales de algunos
de los jefes de estados latinoamericanos
en la primera jornada de la asamblea
general de la onu fueron la oportunidad
para defender las políticas que han
implementado en sus gobiernos hablar
sobre la crisis sanitaria y llamar a la
solidaridad internacional desde ciudad
de mexico el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador dijo que su gobierno está
logrando una cuarta transformación pese
a la crisis económica y sanitaria y nos
hemos propuesto llevar a cabo la cuarta
transformación de la vida pública de
nuestro pues ya hablé de la
independencia de la reforma de la
revolución y ahora de ahora habla de
revolución el presidente de argentina
alberto fernández invitó a la comunidad
internacional a soñar con una vacuna
contra la desigualdad social a pesar de
que su gobierno está acosado por las
críticas a su gestión económica y
sanitaria tenemos que ser capaces de
soñar y construir una vacuna contra la
injusticia social la depredación
ambiental la discriminación en todas sus
formas
siendo pero el país con la tasa de
mortalidad más alta en el mundo por el
joven 19 el presidente hizo un llamado a
la solidaridad para combatir la crisis
sanitaria mundial la pandemia del cobi
19 es el mayor desafío global para la
humanidad desde el fin de la segunda
guerra mundial estoy convencido que
debemos fortalecer el multilateralismo a
través de la onu
por su parte el mandatario colombiano
iván duque hizo un llamado a todos los
países miembros de la organización para
que nos siga como en la llama la
dictadura de nicolás maduro y
necesitamos hacer un llamado enérgico a
todas las naciones del mundo para que
lleven sus voces reclamando elecciones
verdaderamente libres y no la orquesta
prefabricada electoral a la que se
quiere llevar el pueblo venezolano en
este mes de diciembre únicamente para
perpetuar la dictadura hasta el 29 de
septiembre 196 jefes de estado y de
gobierno participarán en la edición 75
de las
general de la onu celebrada este año de
manera típica